Here I have a function h of n,
and she clearly sets the members of an arithmetic progression.
Let's make a quick table here.
We have n and then we have h of n.
When n equals 1, h of n is minus 31,
minus 7 by 1 minus 1, which is zero.
This will be just 0,
so we will have minus 31.
When n equals 2, we will have minus 31
minus 7 by 2 minus 1,
2 minus 1 is just 1,
so we have minus 31 minus 7,
which is equal to minus 38.
When n equals 3,
we will have minus 31 minus 7
3 minus 1, which is 2,
so we'll pull out seven times.
We will have minus 31 minus 14,
which is equal to minus 45.
What do we see happening here?
We start from minus 31
and then proceed by subtracting minus 7.
We continue by subtracting minus 7 of this.
We subtract minus 7 by one time less than the member's number ...
We subtract minus 7 by one less time
from the number of the member we have.
If we look at the third article,
we subtract minus 7 twice.
If we look at the second article,
subtract minus 7 once.
All this is nice,
and now pause the video
and see if you can determine the same arithmetic progression.
The progression here starts from minus 31
and keep it going by taking 7,
so we have minus 38 minus 45.
The next one will be minus 52
and keep going the same way.
Continue to subtract minus 7.
Can you determine this arithmetic progression
by recursively assigning the function?
Why do not you try to do it?
Write the function using a recursive formula.
Let's just call it g of n,
In some respects, the recurrent formula of the function is easier,
because you can say ...
The first article, when n equals 1,
if n equals 1, let me write it,
if n equals 1,
how much will be g from n?
Will be minus 31,
minus 31.
And if n is greater than 1 and is a natural number,
this will be determined for all positive integer numbers
and the natural numbers,
we will have the previous member,
namely g of n minus 1,
minus 7.
If we simply choose an arbitrary member,
we must look at the previous article
and then pull out 7.
All this becomes nice and easy,
because you keep looking
the previous Articles,
until you get to the base case,
which is at n equal to 1,
as you can build them back from it.
And you get exactly the same arithmetic progression.
Let's look at another example,
but this time we will do it the opposite way.
Here we have an arithmetic progression,
defined by recurrent members
and I want to create a feature,
which determines progression apparently.
Let's think about it.
One way to look at this arithmetic progression,
when n equals 1, it starts at 9.6
and then each member is the previous minus 0.1.
The second member will be the previous member
minus 0.1, so it will be 9.5.
Then you will go to 9.4.
Then you will have 9.3.
We can go on and on, and more.
If we want, we can make a small table here
and we could say,
that this is n, it is h of n,
when you see that when n equals 1,
h of n is 9.6.
When n equals 2,
now we are here in this case,
we will have h of 2 minus 1,
which will be h of 1 minus 0.1.
We will have just that minus 0.1,
which will be 9.5.
When h is 3, we will have h of 2,
h of 2 minus 0.1,
h of 2 is here.
You draw a tenth and get 9.4,
exactly what we see here.
Pausing the video now
whether you can define that ...
Create a function that sets or determines
this arithmetic progression apparently.
Here, it was set up recurrently.
We want to make it clear.
Let's just call it,
for example, call it f of n.
We can say we have 9.6,
we will deduct a number of times,
depending on which member we are talking about.
We'll get 0.1,
but how many times will we extract it as a function of n?
Let's see.
If we are talking about the first article,
we remove it 0 times.
Under the second article we remove it one time.
Under the third article, we deduct it twice.
Under the fourth article we remove it three times.
Regardless of which member we are talking about,
we remove that number as many times as the member's number minus 1.
If we talk about nth member,
we subtract this value n minus 1 times.
You can check that this will be the case.
When n equals 1,
this article here will be 0,
so this whole thing will be 0.
You get 9.6.
When n equals 2,
2 minus 1,
you subtract 0.1 only once.
9.6 minus 0.1 is 9.5.
You can continue doing it.
You can draw a table and calculate it.
The key point is that you start at 9.6 and you get 0.1
with less than the number of the member you are looking at.
If n equals 4,
you will draw 0.1 times three times,
You take 0.1 one time,
subtract 0.1 twice,
subtract 0.1 three times.